the 40 year old virgin I found out
almost didn't work out for you after the
first week Universal pulled the plug we
were doing a scene on location somewhere
and Judd Apatow was the director came in
and said just that we've had a break in
shooting he came in and said Universal
wants to talk to us they're shutting us
down
and this was on a Friday afternoon and
so we had to go in and they said we've
been watching footage we'd only been
shooting for five days and we've been
watching footage and you look like a
serial killer
[Laughter]
Steve Carell looked like a cereal and we
hadn't shot any dialogue it was me
riding my bike with a weird helmet and
it was me walking down the street and
seeing suggestive posters and going yeah
just that we compiled yeah they went new
no no no no we're this is not a comedy
you must have been terrified I was so
bummed out I thought that's it that way
that was the big shot and it wasn't
gonna work out and then thankfully we
started up on Monday and finished
shootings yeah yeah I love that you've
gotta always get names down when people
say ah you know no you you you're not
gonna make it kid you don't have what it
takes
it was very for later it was very close